on va quand même parler du combat pour
bakary ce que je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
de bonnes ou mauvaises idées alors
depuis le 1er août 2010 8 les relations
entre ces deux rappeur booba et charisme
cesse de faire parler après un combat à
mains nues à l'aéroport d'orly donc en
août dernier un possible combat entre
les deux rappeurs serait sur le point
d'être organisés ont dit d'arrêter les
parties je vais tout voir
25 juste après j'ai même appelé mathieu
delormeau 6 décembre
parce que je voulais qu'ils participent
qu'ils fassent rares mais grâce à combat
également je vous dirais contre qui
regardent et ses bas si vous n'avez pas
mis le nez sur instagram durant les
vacances vous êtes peut-être passer à
côté de ce qui pourrait être le combat
du siècle nouvelles idées de booba
depuis noël organisé un combat avec
caris pourront terré l'âge de gare une
nouvelle étape dans la guerre qui oppose
les rappeur booba et carris souvenez
vous c'est déjà eu qui avait créé le
buzz cet été en se battant à l'aéroport
d'orly une bagarre générale qui avait
fini par l'interpellation des deux
hommes est une condamnation à 18 mois de
prison avec sursis et 50000 euros
damende depuis boubakary continue de se
lancer des piques sur les réseaux
sociaux
une tradition qui a fini par agacer
booba qui le jour de noël a décidé de
passer d'instagram à la réalité
en proposant à caris de l'affronter sur
un ring une invitation à laquelle le
rappeur a répondu non sans provocation
je te propose un octogone sans arbitre
sans règles je te brise les os le dopage
sera interdit bien évidemment et vient
pas à 12,7 fois le combat qui devrait
avoir lieu en avril est en cours de
préparation un contrat devrait être
signé prochainement entre les deux
protagonistes et ce n'est autre que baba
en personne qui s'est proposé d'être l'
arbitre de cette rencontre au sommet
alors selon vous ce combat est il une
bonne ou une mauvaise idée
alors excuse pas call of the lemon bonne
ou mauvaise idée
alors on pensait donc l'histoire
terminée mais booba a voulu donc
rencontré charisme pour enterrer la
hache de guerre alors je vous le dis
pourquoi ce combat ces voix là ils sont
10 au lieu de lui il s'est dit voilà
j'ai eu au téléphone en bas il a dit au
lieu de se battre voilà dans des
endroits comme des aéroports offrent des
trucs quand on va devoir tout ça c'est
n'importe quoi faisons un combat voilà
tous les deux vraiment un combat de boxe
qui est un noble art non mais c'est vrai
avec et il
il a dit voilà que une partie des fonds
récoltés irait à une association donc je
les ai eus au téléphone je vais parler
peut-être la banque du coeur où ça on
s'est dit peut-être qu'on allait
organiser ce combat caris apparemment a
dit oui voilà qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
une bonne ou mauvaise idée dit la vérité
et vous aussi après je vous donnerai les
obtenons les aboutissants de cette
affaire
bonne ou mauvaise idée vous avez bonne
ou mauvaise un grand spectacle le match
du siècle
c'est un sport de grande valeur valeurs
de respect et de solidarité
est-ce que caresser booba bah oui en pro
et de ses valeurs si ba oui je pense à
karim bah oui c'est pour ça qu'ils
voient ciré bah oui oui effectivement ça
peut pas donner des parce
qu'effectivement ils sont battus aux
religions bref moi j'ai un souci si on
commençait fallait combats organisés en
trois mois je vais vous dire moi moi moi
si ces petites secondes avant que nous
moi je vous dis c'est pas pour
encourager la violence mais au contraire
mais laisser vraiment je vous dirais que
moi quand je les ai vus ce match dans un
aéroport avec des enfants à côté même
boubala dit voilà encore un exemple
impossible là ils sont que c'est encadré
mais moi j'ai peur que si on commence à
dire voilà on va se rencontrer ensemble
va se [__] sur la gueule une âme et si
du citoyen enfin ils sont hypocrites les
autres et il faut passer aux combattants
de mma
moi j'ai pas qu'après des mômes les
amapiens on peut se rencontrer dans un
octogone je vais te casser la gueule
et moi j'ai juste peur de ça après ses
traits loi de l'organiser je suis
d'accord avec vous moi j'ai juste peur
comme toujours du débordement que ça
peut causer et que est une mine de rien
on va organiser un combat entre deux
personnes qui veut pas ça y est on va
pas se mentir qui vont [__] sur la
gueule et moi j'ai un peu près avec ça
alors
alors oui et moi moi ce qui me pose
question surtout c'est ce qu'ils vont
venir voir parce qu'il y aura les
problèmes baccharis comment les services
d'ordre va va réussir à lyon
trop leur disant non à la sorte c'est
passé on a des solutions
on a des solutions à tous et voilà alors
vous pensez de cette bonne idée à moi je
pense que j'ai mis le nul autre à soyons
francs mais justement je reconnais
honnêtement que ça m'amuse beaucoup de
les voir sur un risque dominant remporté
le résultat
moi ce que je pensais 1 c'est pour la
bonne cause tout faire ça alors plutôt
que de les voir se battre dans la région
il ya un problème de risques de
débordements
mauvaise idée joue surtout après oui je
trouve que c'est une mauvaise idée parce
que ils ont été condamnés sur cette
affaire et moi je trouve qu'à une
décision de justice et que ça me semble
prolonger la faire d'une manière
artificielle voilà c'est pour ça que
c'est une mauvaise idée mais non
contraire justement c'est pour y mettre
un point final
ce combat justement ce sera la fin de
ces petites guéguerres sur les réseaux
sociaux
moi je trouve que franchement c'est
plein de testostérone ses limites très
excitant enfin moi je trouve ça
franchement j'ai hâte d'aller voir ce
combat at war quelqu'un au but lui qui
voulait que je fais pas non non mais
quand même fort et voilà on a tous hâte
de voir ce que ça va donner de voir
s'ils vont vraiment se battre s'ils vont
tenir la route parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
parlé donc on a envie de les voir sur le
terrain moi ça me plaît
et pourtant ils font pas une battle de
punch line de rap de machines ont fait
naître
des années dans le monde dit dans la
bonne ou mauvaise idée
moi je pars du principe je vous le dis
moi je préfère cent fois les voir parce
que je suis sûr qu'après des mois de
boxe je vous le dis ce qui se passe ils
vont se tomber dans les bras elle répond
il c'est vrai quoi c'est cette fois
c'est ce que je vois et c'est le plus
important
bref franchement et au moins il ya des
règles on va là ils feront leur truc
après je suis sûr qu'ils vont devenir
pote et au moins c'est un moyen
d'enterrer la hache de guerre au jour
mais moi je crois pas du tout ils
viendront potes à la fin du combat mais
en revanche home on verra qui est plus
fort et commun serena en charrier posée
bah voilà foutez vous sur la gueule mais
dans d un cadre quand même légale on
verra ça sera un moment de télé un
spectacle et voilà on verra bien qui
gagne les deux les deux là ils sont
chauds et mathieu mémé tu as raison sur
trois choses 1 c'est pour une bonne
cause donc voilà deux effectivement à la
skull la boxe est noble et trois sauces
tant que ce soit fait autant que ce soit
bien encadré
là tu as raison au fait vous avez raison
pardon en revanche qui m'ennuie c'est
que la même cette idée malgré tout sous
jacente qui est que quand deux personnes
se détestent et on sait à quel point ce
sont des exemples pour les jeunes la
solution c'est quand même le combat
comme deux animaux on peut quand même
très certainement se mettent autour
d'une table discuter s'excuser
s'entendre il vaut mieux le sport que
les insultes c'est pas des solutions à
sa part le sport c'est beaucoup plus
originaux jean lorsqu'après après je
pense qu'ils vont se mettent autour
d'une table et que ça va mieux placé
après je je pense après je peux me
tromper
raymond moi je vous aime beaucoup
j'aimerais tellement croire qu'ils vont
se prendre dans les bras après le combat
est d'abord sur le truc de la recette je
veux pas que ce soit une partie de la
recette soit l'intégralité de la recette
je veux pas qu'il leur reste un euro à
eux deux parce que c'est quand même des
gens qui sont rentrés dans un aéroport
ils sont bagarrés comme des sauvages que
la vie a gâté il roule en lamborghini iv
voyage en jet ils font le tour du monde
ils ont flingué les vacances de gens
parce qu'il ya des gens qui devaient
prendre des avions jour là ces kits qui
avaient des correspondances prison qui
était là-bas qui devait acheter des tic
tac
je ne présiderai pas revenir là-dessus
en escale sur ton retard quand tu donnes
à l'escale du retard et le traumatisme
que tu as fait devant les enfants qui
étaient là ça sa part été robin des bois
pas pris non je suis pas robin des bois
donc tu te bagarre pas devant les
enfants
ça n'a pas de prix bas c'est pour ça
qu'ils font à main moi je rejoins
benjamin j'ai peur qu'après on se dise
les gars on va aller à l'aéroport on va
se taper et apprend à finir à l'alu
arena moi je veux qu'ils reversent
toutes et tous les sous de le du combat
y reverra
si je monte dans les bras alors alors
voilà alors pour vous expliquer
peut-être trouvé là vous rappelez
foucault jusqu'à grenoble alors je
connais un petit peu car il mais je
connais un petit peu charisme et j'aime
énormément
booba on s'entend très bien voilà et
c'est vrai que voilà il a pensé bagarre
mais pas du tout nous ne regarde gentil
voilà organisation sport il sait que je
suis un fan de boxe walla et de les
agresser de sports de combat voilà îles
scilly peut-être on sait on sait au
téléphone il m'a dit ouais on organise
ensemble et surtout ce qu'on voudrait
faire moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est aussi
pour la banque du coeur ses caresses que
voilà si sa cavale est un nylon pour la
banque du coeur bien sûr bien et si
après eux ils peuvent s'entendre
ça serait génial booba je vous le dis
j'ai eu lui m'a dit moi pour une
association franchement je le fais c'est
génial de il me dit voilà c'est parce
que je veux enterrer la hache de guerre
et jomby voilà qu'on se rencontre au
lieu de faire des vidéos proposées comme
ça qu'on se rencontre sur un ring et
j'ai après je me fais penser à d'autres
combats donc pour cette soirée à vous
voulez combattre contre contre
christophe beaugrand
en rugby c'est la bande du coeur c'est
une bonne cause est ce que tu peux te
battre dans un ré sur un ring contre
christophe beaugrand d'abord je pense
que tu vas bac mon chéri c'est pour une
bonne cause
arrivé à mettre booba et clarisse main
dans la main dans les bras après le
combat oui vous donner des sous à la
banque du coeur à des assos dans l'un
des messages que vous envoyez le châssis
ce que je veux faire
voilà et mamies et moraux et moi alors
moi je vois là je fais un appel 6 e
voilà franchement aussi yann barthès à
l'achat pas bouclé montre moi si joey
starr me combattre contre moi et même
s'ils veulent comme je suis un petit peu
à gagner s'ils veulent battre combattent
même tous les trois en même temps y'a
aucun souci franchement tu accepterais
pour la banque du coeur de battre toi tu
fais ah bah oui bien sûr alors bien sûr
on pieds poings voilà bien sûr
kickboxing ci veut il ya aucun problème
voilà et bien sûr bien encadré et je
suis sûr qu'à la fin on se tombe dans
les bras et qu'on mange rien à manger
une marguerite et ensemble parce que je
préfère ça que de se battre dans la rue
main vous de faire baisser les stores
ses fans de sports de combat et la
première chose
la première chose qu'on apprend aux
sports de combat c'est de ne pas d'être
violon dans la rue voilà je dis est vrai
que c'est pas le bon exemple si vous
avez dit tout à l'heure